all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon to brief you
on a homicide investigation
that we are conducting in the 4300 block
of west flamingo
the details that i have right now are
very preliminary but at around 3 p.m
this afternoon we responded
on report of two women deceased inside
of a hotel room directly behind me
medical personnel arrived along with
metro police and determined both the
females
were deceased what we have learned is
that
late this afternoon the hotel guest had
not checked out of the room
security went to make contact with the
occupant
they were unable to get into the room
due to the security latch being engaged
maintenance was requested and they
responded to the room and were able to
force
entry into the room where they
discovered the bodies
of two black adult females laying
on the bed in the hotel room deceased
what we believe from evidence inside the
room is that this is going to be a
murder-suicide investigation
so again it's still very early on in the
investigation
i'll take a couple questions if you have
them but i don't really have much more
than that at this point
are they tourists we believe they're
going to be locals from the information
that we're getting we're still trying to
positively identify both of them we have
some preliminary information
that leads us to believe that they are
going to be local residents
we believe within the last 12 hours we
know that
at least one of them was alive as early
as five o'clock this morning
we're thinking mid to late 30s
are going to be the age range
they are both uh we believe both are
going to have gunshot wounds and that's
what's going to be the
cause of death
we don't know the answer to that
question uh the question was if they
were both
if they both died at the same time we
don't know the answer to that that's
what we're
we're trying to figure out right now
working with security to go through
video surveillance
and piecing all that together
again anytime we have a homicide
investigation there's going to be a
significant police presence just to make
sure that the scene is secure
and especially with the footprint that
homicide and csi
brings there's always going to be a
large presence with that you're still
working to positively identify
uh from a note that was left in the room
we believe that they
are going to be at least somewhat
romantically involved but again i don't
have the specifics of that
did any other guest hear the gun at this
point there are no reports that anybody
has heard anything we're still
canvassing and speaking with anybody who
may have heard anything
can you tell us more about that no okay
so
all right thank you guys take care